احييكم مشاهدينا العربيه ما زالت مستمره
في هذه التغطيه لليوم السادس لهذا النزاع
المسلح في السودان بين الجيش السوداني
وبين قوات الدعم السريع لا صوت في السودان
يعلو فوق صوت الرصاص الان لاهن في الاجواء
ولانيه لدى الجنرلين لوقف المعارك خلاف
على السلطه بين الزعيمين العسكريين لم
تحتويه صداقه العقدين تصدعات عده بدات منذ
عام 2021
زادها اتساعا دمج قوات الدعم السريع
بالجيش ما دفع بعلاقه عمرها سنوات بين
البرهان وحميتي للانهيار
[موسيقى]
20 عاما قضاياها رفيقي درب وسلاح خندق
واحد جمع الضابطين اللذين عمل جنبا الى
جنب في ميادين القتال قبل ان يخرق صمت
المماطله بالاتفاق رصاص اوقع وحده الصف
وارهق صداقه امتدت لعقدين من الزمن
ابن بادر بسيط نجاه في قامت السودان كل
منهما يتحذر من مدرسه قتاليه مغيره صرامه
عسكريه وتمرس بمطارده الحركات المسلحه
جمعت بينهما ضرورات مرحليه تتقاطع مع ظروف
حرب دارفور عام 2003 فهناك كان اللقاء
الاول بين عبد الفتاح البرهان ومحمد حمدان
دقلو
حينها كان البرهان ضابطا بسلاح المشاه في
مقاد احمدتي عشرات المسلحين لحمايه
الاهالي وقوافل تجارتهم التجااز تقاسم
مهامه وذخيره صعدت بعدها العلاقه تدريجيا
وان عن بعد قبل ان يدور الزمن ويعيدهما
لصداره المشهد عام 2019
تحالف عسكري سياسي هذه المره بهدف اسقاط
حكم البشير تحت ضغط الاحتجاجات الشعبيه
ليمتطيا معا صهوه فتره انتقاليه كان يؤمل
منها قياده البلاد نحو الديمقراطيه
مجلس عسكري له اخر عرف بمجلس السياده
الانتقاليه تراسهما تباعا البرهان منتقيا
في كل مره صديقه للنيابه عنه
هذه العلاقه ظلت خاليه من التشويش لحين
اصطدامها بحائط رمي المسؤوليه عن فض
اعتصام القياده عام 2019
فبرزت شروخ داخل المكون العسكري تلملمت
على الاقل ظاهريا احمدتي اي دام وصف
بانقلاب الخامس والعشرين من اكتوبر ثم
تاسف عنه وامتعض من اعاده قائد الجيش
لعناصر النظام السابق للسلطه واتسعت
الفجوه اكثر مع توقيع الاتفاق الايطالي
والخلاف على الجداول الزمنيه لدمج قوات
الدعم السريع بالقوات المسلحه خلاف عجزت
مسيره الشراكه الطويله عن احتوائه وبين
العشاء الاول في دارفور والعشاء الاخير في
الخرطومه ذابت القضيه مع محاوله الاسراع
بتذويب الدعم السريع داخل الجيش بصفه
نهائيه
من الخرطوم ينضم الى مراسل العربيه سالم
الهاشمي سالم اهلا بك معنا بعد ان انتهت
هذه الهدنه الوضع لديك الان
نعم الاوضاع الان بدات اكثر طبيعيه او
هدوء هناك هدوء الان واضح في مجمل
العاصمه الخرطوم
عدا بعض المناطق
وهذه المناطق متفرقه لكن بحسب المصادر ان
المنطقه التي فيها الاشتباك الان هي في ام
درمان
هذه المصادر اكدت ان هناك اشتباك في ام
درمان في ام بده وهذه منطقه لم يكن فيها
اشتباك من قبل بقيه المناطق يشوبها العديد
من الحب يعني لماذا تتركز الاشتباكات هناك
هي لم تتركز وانما هذه المنطقه جديده
بالفعل لم يكن هناك اشتباك من قبل في هذه
المنطقه على الاطلاق اي لم تشهد
اشتباكا من قبل هي منطقه مبدا كانت
الاشتباكات في ام درمان في محيط القياده
العامه في المهندسين كذلك كانت في كل ان
يحسمها الجيش السوداني
الان في هناك اشتباكات لم ترد الينا
تفاصيل هذه الاشتباكات حتى الان عن
اسبابها وما الذي نجم عنها لكن هذه هي
التي وردت الينا حتى الان بقيه المناطق في
الخرطوم تشهد هدوء نسبيا
هناك بدات حركه للمواطنين في بعض المناطق
استعدادا ليوم عيد الفطر الاول او محاوله
لاستعداد اليه لانه خاصه ان هناك مناطق
تنعدم فيها المياه والان هو هذا التركيز
على موضوع المياه لجلبها لاستخدامها
للاستعداد للعيد نفسه
قد حل
موضوع المياه والكهرباء حل جزئيا ولم يحل
كليا اللي هو المهم ايضا هناك مناطق
بالفعل حلت مشكله المياه فيها لكن هناك
مناطق ما زالت مشكله المياه فيها قائمه
اتحدث عن مدينه بحري باحيائها الكبرى
الموجوده
باتجاهات الجسور كلها كلها لا توجد فيها
مياه ابتداء من كوبر وحتى شامبات الشعبيه
الصافيه المغتربين حله حمل بكل هذه
المناطق كل هذه المناطق ليست بها مياه حتى
الان الناس يخرجون الائمه للابرار
الارتوازيه
وهناك محاولات التي تقوم بها بعض لجان
الاحياء وكذلك
الناشطين في هذا المجال
يعني جلب مياه من بعيد لوصولها الى هنا
للمساعده للمواطنين من اجل ان يستقبلوا
يوم العيد الاول على الاقل
اليوم او هل استطاعوا اليوم ان تفتح بعض
المحال التجاريه حتى يستطيعوا ان يجلبوا
احتياجاتهم
للاحتفال بعيد الفطر المبارك
نعم كلمه احتفال للعيد
هكذا اوضاع يكون احتفال ولكن اقله يعني
هذا
على الانسان ايضا ان يشعر به حتى ولو بهذه
الظروف
صحيح نتمنى ان يكون عيد بالفعل ونتمنى ان
يكون هو احتفال
نتمنى ان يكون احتفال الحقيقي بالفعل تكون
هناك على الاقل نسبي وبالنسبه للمواطنين
ولو ليوم واحد يعني على الاقل
هذا بالنسبه للمحل التجاري الغالب في
المناطق التي حدثت فيها الاشتباكات او
بالقرب منها ليس الغالب بل هو العم يعني
انه في هذه المناطق لا توجد محل تجاريه
تعمل على الاطلاق حتى الاماكن شراء المواد
الغذائيه للبقالاتها وتعمل من خلفي
الابواب يعني لا يفتحون الباب فقط حينما
تتحدث ستطلب ما تريد وتتم مناولتك
الغرض ان كان موجودا وهناك اغراض غير
موجوده في محل البقالات كنا في جوله مع مع
بعض اصحاب البقالات وقد شكوا من قله
الامداد فيما يتعلق ببعض السلع بعينها
ابرزها الماء نفسه لا يوجد مياه في
البقالات الان كذلك الدقيق
فيه ايضا ندره كذلك كذلك الافران ايضا لا
تعمل كلها بكامل طاقتها هناك افران تعمل
وفران لا تعمل هذا ما شكل ايضا ندره في
سلعه في سلعه الخبز كذلك لكن في هذه
المناطق لا توجد محل تجاريه تعمل المحل
التجاريه التي تعمل بعيدا عن اماكن
الاشتباكات وهذا ايضا يجعل المواطنين
الموجودين في محيط مناطق الاشتباكات من
الصعوبه ان يصلوا الى هناك بحكم ان
الشوارع ما زالت يعني في نظر الكثير من
المواطنين غير امنه وان الحركه فيها صعبه
كذلك في ظل انقطاع التواصل بين المدن
الثلاث يعني سالم على الرغم من الهدنه
لمده
24 تقديم المساعدات الانسانيه اقله وان
كان طبيه او غذائيه
هذه المسارات تطالب
يبدو بانه فقدنا الاتصال بسالم سنذهب الى
عمار ابو شيبه ايضا هو من الخرطوم بحري
حيث تركزت بالامس الاشتباكات هناك عمار
اهلا بك معنا كيف يبدو الوضع الان في
الخرطوم بحري
يعني اهلا بك واهلا بمشاهدين الكرام في
مدينه بحري هنالك هدوء نوعا ما كانت هنالك
اصوات قبل ساعات او دقائق من الان
المضادات الارضيه بعدد من الاتجاهات الان
الوضع فيه هدوء وهو ربما هدوء حاذر جدا في
هذه المنطقه خاصه وان عديد من اطراف
المدينه شهيده حالات للسلب والنعم من خلال
نهار اليوم ولكن هنالك هدوء حذير ايضا
التيار الكهربائي يعني بدا يستقر نوعا ما
مع انقطاع للمياه لليوم على التوالي وهذا
نشاهده من خلال كثير جدا من المناطق التي
تشتكي وترسل العديد من الرسائل بان
الكهرباء والمياه في
هنالك استقرار في الطياره الكهربائي
وايضا خدمه شراء الكهرباء كانت قد عملت
لفتره محدوده قبل قليل تطبيق بنكك الذي من
خلاله يستطيع المواطنون ان يشتروا
الكهرباء كان فيه تعطيل الان ربما اشتغل
هذا التطبيق لساعات وسطاء من خلاله عدد من
المواطنين
يحصلوا على خدمه الكهرباء من خلال الشراء
هناك انقطاع بين الفتره والاخرى وربما هذا
بحسب يعني الاخبار التي ترد بذلك مشاكل في
توزيع الامداد الكهربائي ولكن هي تستقر
لساعات
نعم خاصه وان السوق السوق الكبير سوق بحري
كان هنالك في حريق بالامس
ونشاهد الذين سلبوا هذه الاسواق وهذه
المحاله التجاريه داخل الاحياء وهم
يتجولون وبايديهم عدد من الاشياء الذين
الذي تم سلبها ونهبها منهم بشكل واضح
هنالك كلمه المؤسسه التعاونيه في شارع
الشهيد مطر شارع الانقاذ سابقا تم نهبها
بشكل كبير جدا وهذه كانت واحده من الاسواق
التي خصصها الجيش من الفترات لتقدم خدمه
للمواطنين باسعار ارخص من اسعار السوق
العام شكرا لك عمار ابو شبا كنت معي من
الخرطوم بحري اي جديد نعود اليك والى ايضا
زميلنا سالم
وطبعا نعود ونذكر بان هناك هدوء حذر الان
في الخرطوم بحري بعد الاشتباكات بين الجيش
والدعم السريع
[موسيقى]
كويس
مستغلين بعضهم
مستغلين بعضهم بقت تمام
[موسيقى]
والله سلامه
وربنا يحققنا الدماء
من رب العالمين ان شاء الله ربنا
مع المسلمين
[موسيقى]
على واقع الرصاص والمعارك الطاحنه التي
تعصف في السودان تفجرت موجه نزوح الاف
المدنيين الذين بداوا يغادرون منازلهم
بعضهم بالسيارات والبعض الاخر سييرا على
الاقدام يفررون بحثا عن اماكننا اكثر امنا
نتابع من جديد حاله من الذعر والخوف تنتاب
المدنيين في السودان على وقع زخات الرصاص
والمعارك الكثيفه التي حاصرت مساكنهم رغم
هدنه هشه كسابقتها ما دفع الالاف لجمع
امتعتهم والمصارعه بالفرار تجنبا لنيران
قوات الدعم السريع والجيش السوداني
حاله الذعر لم تقتصر على المواطنين
السودانيين فقط بل امتدت الى الاجانب
والبعثات الدبلوماسيه التي بادرت بعمليه
تنظيم رعاياها تمهيدا لنقلهم خارج السودان
بعدما بدات بالفعل دول مثل المانيا
واليابان خططا لاجلاء مواطنيها لكن من
المؤكد ان الاضرابات المستمره واغلاق
المطارات الرئيسيه ستعيق تلك الخطط مصادر
مطلع افادت بان مهمه الجيش الالماني
لاجلاء نحو 150 المانيه من السودان ارجات
بسبب القتال الدائر في العاصمه الخرطوم
وعدم التزام الطرفي الصراع بالهدنه
الثانيه التي تنتهي مساء اليوم كذلك تحدثت
اليابان عن وجود حوالي 60 مواطنا يابانيا
بينهم موظفون في السفاره بالخرطوم فمع
استمرار اغلاق المطارات تعتبر الامم
المتحده ان خطه الاخلاء الفوري جوا
مستحيلا ما دعا الى النظر في امكانيه
استخدام الطرق البريه رغم المخاطر
الكارثيه التي تحيط بها
حصيله قتل المواجهات متضاربه لكنها تجاوزت
مئات القتلى والاف الجرحى وهي تبقى مرشحه
للارتفاع مع استمرار الصراع بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع في قلب العاصمه
الخرطوم ومناطق اخرى من البلاد
الله اكبر الله اكبر ازمه تركت اثارها على
الجوانب المعيشيه للمواطنين وضاعفت اسعار
المواد الغذائيه حتى المرافق الصحيه لم
تسلم كذلك من تبعات الصراع حيث اجبرت
المستشفيات المرضى على مغادرتها لنقص
امكانيات العلاج والاقامه ومع استمرار
الاشتباكات اصبح من الواضح انه لا يوجد
مكان امن في السودان لحياه المدنيين
من الخرطوم ينضم الى حيدر احمد مسؤول
الاعلام في هيئه مياه الخرطوم استاذ حيدر
اهلا بكم معنا موضوع المياه هو المشكله
الاكبر الان في الخرطوم حسب الانباء
الكهرباء يبدو بانها حلت مشكلتها وعادت
جزئيا اقله ولكن موضوع المياه ماذا يمكن
ان تطلعنا حول هذا الموضوع
تحيه لك وتحيه للمشاهدين القناه وكل عام
وانتم بخير
نستطيع ان نقول ان عدد من محافظه المياه
في الخرطوم
عاد الى الخدمه بشكل جيد في مناطق جنوب
وشرق ووسط الخرطوم
يعني عندنا محطه تعمل بطاقات القصوى ومحطه
الشجره في وسط الخرطوم بشكل كامل استاذ
حيدر
تدخلت الطواجن الفنيه وعاليه مشاكل فنيه
المحطات
بشكل الكهرباء
والان الموجود في هذه المناطق في وسط
الخرطوم
ما الذي يحول دون عوده المياه الى كل
المناطق استاذ حيدر يعني بالامس كنت
تتحدثون بانه عمال الهيئه لا يستطيعون
الوصول الى بعض المناطق هل هذا الامر ما
زال قائما امس استطعتم ان تؤمنوا لهم
ممرات امنه للوصول
في محطه مياه بحري ومحطه مياه بري
ومحقق مياه بيت المال
المحطات لا تزال يعني
محيط الاستئناف
العمال الفنيين المهندسين الدخول لهذه
المحطات خطر على حياتنا
وبالتالي
يسعد يعني تشغيل هذه المحطات في هذه
الظروف
طب هل من جهود مع الاطراف المتنازعه لان
يؤمنوا هذه المنطقه اقله حتى تعود المياه
الى المواطنين ام لا اتصال مع الاطراف
المنازعه متنازعه
نعم نعم
يضرب
استاذ حيدر يعني اعذرني ولكن الصوت من
المصدر رديء لا نستطيع ان نسمعك بوضوح
نحاول ان نعود اليك خلال هذه النشره او
النشرات اللاحقه حتى الان اشكرك حيدر احمد
مسؤول الاعلام في هيئه مياه الخرطوم كنت
معي من الخرطوم
على طاوله العشاء اجتمع ليلا وفي ساحه
القتال تواجه صباحا هذه تفاصيل الساعات
الاخيره قبل انزلاق السودان الى صراع دموي
وفقه صحيفه نيويورك تايمز
ضجيج اليات العسكر لم يهدا لخمسه ايام مضت
لكنه تسلل من ليله هانئه شهدت عشاء اخيرا
بين الجنالين هدوء ظاهري اخفى تحت الطاوله
مخططات جاهزه للتحشيد واطلاق رصاصه الاولى
طرفات صراع قطع وعودا وقدمات تنازلات
بحضور وسطاء بهدف نزع فتيل التنافس بينهما
وفق صحيفه نيويورك تايمز وفيما كانت
الالات العسكريه المتنافسه تستعد للقتال
تدفقت القوات بهدوء على معسكرات الجيش
المتنافسه في جميع انحاء العاصمه الخرطوم
بدايه الخلاف وبحسب الصحيفه خرجت من قلق
حمد المتمثل باختراق الجيش من قبل موالينا
للنظام السابق فيما بدات المخابرات
العسكريه بقياده البرهان في اخبار
المسؤولين الاجانب بان حمد حاول سرا
استيراد طائرات مسلحه من دون طيار من
تركيا لتعزيز قوته فالخلافات لوحدت حتى
بين افراد الجيش والدعم السريع الذين
تعاملك قوتين متنافستان وليس منسجمتين ضمن
نفس الدوله لكن ما ادى الى تفاقم الخلاف
اكثر محاوله الاتفاق على دمج القوتين في
جيش واحد خصوصا ان هذه العمليه ستخرج
حمدتي الخاسره الاكبر منها
الانقلاب على الاتفاقات لم يكن الاول في
تاريخ الطرفين ففي عام 2021 فاجا
الجنرالان مبعوث الاميركي حين سقطت
الحكومه المدنيه في مسار الطريق السودان
الى الديمقراطيه عقبات كثيره وامال
الوسطاء بالتوصل لاتفاق صعبه بعد ان فجر
كل من الطرفين نواياه بوجه الاخر اياد
حمود العربيه
يعاني الوضع الصحي في السودان من تدهور
كبير في ظل تعرض مستشفيات للقصف وانقطاع
الكهرباء عنها ياتي هذا خاصه وان القطاع
الصحي في هذا البلد يعاني من الهشاشه منذ
سنوات عديده نتابع
الوضع الصحي في السودان على حافه الهاويه
اغلب المستشفيات خارج الخدمه بلغه الارقام
70% من المرافق الصحيه توقفت عن العمل او
اجبرت على ذلك وفق نقابه الاطباء
السودانيين من اصل 74 مستشفى في العاصمه
هو الولايات القريبه من مناطق الاشتباك 52
منها اصبحت خارج الخدمه تماما تسعه
مستشفيات تعرضت للقصف الشديد ما يعني وجود
اثنين وعشرين مستشفى في المنطقه لكنها
مهدده بالاغلاق في اي لحظه هناك حاليا
يعني حوالي 16 مستشفى في عموم السودان
وبالاخص تسعه في الخرطوم خرجت عن الخدمه
بسبب الهجمات العسكريه هناك ما يقارب من
عدد مستشفى مهدده بالتوقف عن العمل بسبب
الارهاق العاملين الصحيين هناك نقص في
توفر الكهرباء والمياه النظيفه
ايضا من الخرطوم ينضم الينا دكتور محمد
ابراهيم عبد الرحمن المتحدث باسم وزاره
الصحه في السودان دكتور اهلا بكم معنا كيف
يمكن ان تقيم وضع المستشفيات بعد يعني
اقفال العديد من المستشفيات
بسبب عدم حصولها على اي امدادات طبيه وحتى
الكادر الطبيه يعني لا يستطيع الوصول
اليها ماذا يمكن ان تفيدنا بهذا الشان
السلام عليكم احييكم واحيي الجميع الشعب
السوداني تحيه الصحه والعافيه
والرحمه والمغفره للذين ارواحهم الى
بارئها وحييكم الغطاء الصحي الذي مازال
يقدم الخدمات الصحيه
لمرضى السودان
هذه الظروف بالغه التعويض الوضع الصحي في
السودان مازال بخير وفي ولايه الخرطوم على
وجه الخصوص ما زال بخير انا سمعت التصريح
ده هو عاري عن الصحه تماما
عندما تخرج عن الخدمه اكثر من يعني يقال
بانه 39 مستشفى خرجت عن الخدمه
كيف يمكن ان يكون بخير في الخدمه هذا
الكلام غير دقيق غير دقيق اطلاقا انا رسمي
باسم وزاره الصحه
بديكم المعلومات حتى بالامس دكتور اسمح لي
اسمح لي ان اعقب على هذه النقطه بالامس
كان احد من زملائك من وزاره الصحه تحدث عن
103 مستشفيات بانها خرجت عن الخدمه هذا
كان بالامس
103 هي تعمل
وثلاثون لا يعملون
نعم
انا اديك
المعطيات الرسمي اي كلام عن وزاره الصحه
غير غير الجهه المسؤوله يعتبر كلام غير
دقيق
طبعا عدد المستشفيات التي تقدم الخدمه 133
مستشفى 53 مستشفى القطاع العام وواحد
القطاع الخاص المستشفيات دي في الوضع في
وضع السلم
المواطنين يستغلون فقط 30% من مقدره
الاستيعابيه للعيان
الان المستشفيات خارج الخدمه من القطاع
العام 10 مستشفيات لانها في مرمى النيران
تم تفريغ العيانين لمسلسلات اكثر امانا
مستشفيات بديله
القطاع الخاصه التي خرجت قبل الخدمه
المستشفى الان اليوم خمسه مستشفيات عدد
الخدمه خدمه منها 15 ايضا في مرمى النار
تم تفريغ العيانين الى مستشفيات امنه
ومستشفيات السلاح السلاح الطبي
تاملت لكم ممرات امنه حتى قمتم باجلاء
هؤلاء المرضى الى مستشفيات اخرى استاذ
محمد
مستشفى كفيله بتقديم الخدمات
الموجوده في المستشفيات الحد الادنى
لتقديم الخدمات الاولويه الخدمات الطارئه
والخدمات
المسلسلات الان تساوي اثنين الى اربعه في
الوقت الطبيعي الان المستشفيات تستقبل في
المتوسط من يوم 15 وحتى تاريخ اليوم فجر
اليوم من 200 الى 400 حاله يوميا هذا
يساوي اثنين في الميه من المقدع
الاستعابيه للمستشفيات
دكتور هل يمكن ان تطلعنا اذا كانت هذه
المستشفيات لديها ما يكفي من المستلزمات
الطبيه هل الكادر الطبي قادر ان يصل الى
هذه المستشفيات الطبيه الان ما في اي
مستشفى طلبت اي معينات بتاعه مستهلكات
المستهلكات الموجوده فيها الان تكفي
التردد
البديهه من المسيفات اضف الى ذلك عندنا
الامدادات الصحيه في منطقه الخرطوم ودواء
مؤسسه الدواء الدائري وصندوق الدواء
الدائري في منطقه بحري الان
الوزاره عبر اسعافاتها تنقل الكوادر الحد
الادنى من الكوادر للمستشفيات العامله
الاكثر امانا المستشفيات الطرفيهات
المحليه طب بالنسبه للسيارات الاسعاف
دكتور محمد هل تواصلتم مع الاطراف
المتنازعه لتامين مسارات امنه لهم حتى
يستطيعوا التحرك
نعم تم التواصل الان الاسعافات تتحرك في
مناطقها
لحد تاريخ اللحظه وما احتجنا لانه نحرك
اسعاف يعبر الجسور اها كل المسيفات الان
في المسيفات المحليه بسبع ولايات تم اخلاء
منطقه الخرطوم اللي هي المنطقه الاكثر
ضررا بالاشتباكات من الكوادر الصحيه ومن
المرضى دكتور هل لديك اخر احصائيه عن عدد
الوفيات وعدد الاصابات نعم عدد الاصابات
من تاريخ صباح 15 وحتى فجر اليوم
1722 حاله اصابه
الوفيات 105 حاله وفاه موثقه
اما وفاء اثناء تقديم الخدمات الصحيه او
وفاء لتاكيد الوفاء من خارج من خارج
المستشفى
العسكريين انهم 15 حاله المصابين من
العسكريين الذين وردوا الى هزيمه التلقي
لعلاج 186 حاله
عدد العمليات الكبيره الهجريه عمليات
استخراج
الاعين الناريه من الراس والصدر او البطن
اول
حوض او الكسور المركبه 318 عمليه منها 251
عمليه في القطاع العام 67 عمليه بالقطاع
الخاص وهنالك 31 حاله في العينين مكثفه 13
حاله في القطاع العام و18 حاله في القطاع
الخاص
وصلت الى المشارح 50 جثمان وجميع الجسامين
تم تسليمهم الى
كنا بالامس تابعنا بعض الفيديوهات الجثث
ملقات في الشارع هل تمكن سيارات الاسعاف
ان تنقل هذه الجثث ام لا علم لديك بهذا
الامر بعد مناشدتنا عبر الغرفه المركزيه
مع الجهاز وتصلها الان طلع تعميم بانه
قوات الشرطه
نزلت الى الشوارع
لاجلال جسامنا للمشارح
مع عبد الرحمن المتحدث باسم وزاره الصحه
في السودان
اذا مشاهدينا في هذه الصوره الخاصه
بالعربيه كنا استمعنا الى اطلاق اعير
ناريه وايضا اصوات قويه من الممكن ان تكون
لقذائف واسلحه
او ذخيره ثقيله على كل حال سنتابع الان من
طبعا قصه ماساويه ساره عثمان هي فتاه
الثانيه والعشرين من عمرها ضحيه جديده في
اشتباكات الجيش وقوات الدعم السريه في حي
الفتحات بمدينه ام درمان اصابتها رصاصه
طائشه في محيط سكنها استقرت الرصاصه في
قلبها فيما كانت تجلب الماء المنعدم منذ
ايام لاسرتها كاميرا العربيه زارت الاسره
المفجوعه ونقلت معاناتها
[موسيقى]
اجانا الولد جاري قال يا اخي انضربت ما
معروف انضربت بشنو بس وقعت في الوضع
حتى عرفنا انها مضروبه في جهه مهمه
من الخرطوم ينضم الى المحلل العسكري فريق
فتح فتح الرحمن محي الدين اهلا بكم سعاده
الفريق بالنسبه لليوم السادس لهذه
الاشتباكات لهذا النساء النزاع المسلح بين
قوات الدعم السريع وبين الجيش السوداني
كيف يمكن ان تقيم الوضع
يبدو بانه فقدنا الاتصال مع المحلل
العسكري الفريق فتح الرحمن محي الدين
ساذهب الان الى الصحافه سامي محمد سكرتير
عام نادي الصحافه السودانيه استسامي اهلا
بك معنا هذا اليوم السادس لهذا النزاع
المسلح الهدنه انتهت وكنا منذ قليل نتابع
على شاشه العربيه وعبر كاميرا العربيه في
الخرطوم بانه الاشتباكات ما زالت متواصله
على رغم من انه خفت وتيرتها كيف هو الوضع
الان
وماذا نتوقع في الساعات القادمه
هل هل من الممكن انه تمدد هذه الهدنه
الوضع حاليا في الخرطوم صعب جدا ومروع
للمواطنين
وحاليا الاقتتال على اوجهه
واشتدادا الاختتال من قبل الجيش
وتكفيل الخرطوم على شكل مربع بافتاء
العسكريه كبيره جدا
يحاول الجيش دمج القوات المليشيات الدعم
السريع خلال يومين قبل ان يكون سنتين او
عشر سنين كما طلب الدعم السريع
الدعم السريع حاليا وهو يحاول من خلال هو
بعض المنشطاء معهم انه يكونوا هم البديل
للجيش
وتكوين جيش بديل كما حدث في عدد من الدول
العربيه
وتفكيكه وهذا ما لم يسمح به الجيش ولم
يسمح به تسمح به القوات المسلحه
فسوف تكون كبيره جدا في الايام القادمه
لانه الجيش
جلب غالبيه اعتاده وغالبيه القوات منه من
الولايات الى الخرطوم
فنسال ان يكون هناك عقلاء بوقف هذه الحرب
يتضرر المواطنين وتتضرر الخرطوم كعاصمه
بالامس كنت محاصر وغير قادر على الخروج هل
يمكن ان تصف لنا الوضع اليوم كيف يبدو
اليوم الوضع يسود هدوء نسبي حاليا في هذا
المساء
كان بعض المناوشات
بعض في في اماكن متفرقه من ولايه الخرطوم
او من العاصمه المثلث الخرطوم بحري ام
درمان الى الان حاليا
[موسيقى]
في العاصمه لكن الوضع غير مطمن الجميع
يتخوفون
وحاله هروب جماعيه من من الخرطوم كل
السكان ينزحون الى الجزيره
او لانه
الجيش بمحاصرته الى الخرطوم هذا يدل على
ان المعركه القادمه
للصوره على شاشه العربيه حيث هناك
اشتباكات ونستمع الى اطلاق اعيره ناريه
يمكن ان تكمل الاستسامي
القوات المسلحه حاليا هي
لا تريد ان تخوض هذه الحرب لانه الدعم
السريع يحتمل حاليا بالمواطنين ويعملهم قد
حمايه اغوات المسلحه عاليا تسعى الى جانب
التفاوض كما طرحوه سعاده الرئيس مجلس
سعاده الرئيس المجلس العسكري
الفريق عبد الف البرهان ان هناك يمكن ان
نجلس الى التفاوض اذا خرج الدعم السريع من
ولايه الخرطوم حاليا هذا اصبح مطلق من قبل
بعض الاحزاب وبعض العقلاء انه ان يخرج
حمايه من خارج الخرطوم ويجلس
هذا ما نامله خلال الساعات هل من مؤشرات
على قبول الدعم السريع بهذا الامر هل
لديكم اي معلومات حول مؤشرات ايجابيه
لن يقبل من خلال خطاباته لن يقبل وبل بل
هناك بعض الناس وبعض الاشخاص وبعض
المحللين يقولون ان هذا المشروع عد له من
10 سنين تقويه شوكه الدعم السريع والتهون
معه حتى اصبح من اقوى من القوه انه اصبح
هو اطماع سياسيه واطماع اقتصاديه واصبح هو
مسيطر على كل شيء هو حاليا يسعى ان يكون
بديل للجيش
عايزين يكون اصبح بديل للجيش كما حدث في
العراق وكما حدث في اليمن
معه خلاله عدد من المدنيين الى تفكيك
الجيش السوداني
وتبديله بمليشيات حتى يسهل خوض قمار
السياسه فيهم وتعليهم في المناصب وسيطرتهم
على البلاد وهذا ما لم يوافق عليه كثير من
السودانيين وكثير من الدول الاقليميه الى
ان هذه الحرب تساهم فيها العديد من الدول
الاقليميه بالمساهمه الفعاله بدعم السريع
كمواطنين كاعلاميين نطلب ونطلب نحن نطلب
الى الجلوس الى التفاوض سواء كانت دمج في
سنتين سواء كانت دمج في 10 سنين هؤلاء
المواطنين مساكين لا لا اقبل لهم بالحرب
والسودان ذو اغنى اقتصاديه والوضع
الانساني اصبح مزري جدا الجثث مرميه في
الشارع الوضع الطبي اصبح سيء جدا الوضع
الاقتصادي البلد كلها في وضع الاقتصادي
مهزوز جدا جدا حاليا نحن نطالب ونناشد
اعلاميين وعقلاء بوقف هذه الحرب شكرا لك
الصحفي سامي محمد سكرتير عن نادي الصحافه
السودانيه من الخرطوم يعود لينضم الينا
المحل العسكري الفريق فتح هذا الرحمن محي
الدين حضره الفريق اهلا بك معنا هل تسمعني
الان
تقييمك لليوم السادس لهذا النزاع المسلح
يعني على الرغم من 6 ايام هناك هدنه لم
يتم الالتزام بها بشكل كبير اليوم كيف
يبدو الوضع وكيف يمكن ان تقيمه
الوضع اليوم افضل طبعا من الايام اللي
فاتت عن اليوم افضل من امس افضل من اول
امس يعني اول امس كان يمكن اكثر دراوه لكن
امس واليوم اغلنا
كاننا ماضون الى محلال لهذا التمرد
وبالتالي انا اتوقع انه غدا ايضا سيكون
العنف فيه اغلاء لم تصمت الهدنه وغالبا
يعني انا لست متفائلا بهذه الهدنه حقيقه
لانه واضح ان يعني مجموعات الدعم السريعه
اصبحت تعمل اسلوب حرب العصابات كما ذكرتها
قبل ذلك وهي مجموعات اصبحت منعزله كل
مجموعه تعمل في اتجاه مختلف يمكن عدا
المتمركزين في منطقه الرياض ومنطقه حي
المطار هذه داخل المنطقه المركزيه هذه
التي تدور فيها يوميا الهجوم على القياده
العامه هؤلاء فقط يمكن يكونوا هم الذين
تحت سيطره قياده الدعم السريع يعني حضره
الفريق حضره الفريق يعني نفهم من من حديثك
بانه لن لن ياتمروا الموجودين او القاده
الميدانيين على الارض لن ياتمروا بقرارات
قائد قوات الدعم السريع ولذلك هذه الهدنه
دائما كانت هشه
احتمالين اما انهم لم يعتبروا او في
الغالب انه
معلومه لم يتمكن يعني غاده الدعم الس
ريع وبالتالي
يستمر لانه لاحظنا بالامس الهدنه فشلت
لانه شموا هجوم على القياده العامه حول
الساعه الخامسه واستمر الهجوم الى ما بعد
الساعه السابعه مثال يعني جاء زمن الهدنه
والقتال على شده
فهذا يعني يؤكد انها ولدت ميته ايضا اليوم
الذي قبله كنا نتهيا لاننا سندخل في هدنه
24 ساعه
وتفاجئت القياده العامه بهجوم قبل ربع
ساعه من زمن الهدنه وايضا يعني فشلت
الهدنه بهذا الاسلوب لكن يعني انا اعتقد
انه الهدنه يعني ستفرد نفسها وتفرض نفسها
لانه المجموعات التي تؤدي الى الان يعني
بدات تستهلك يعني كثرت فيها الخسائر كثره
فيها فقدان المعدات كسر فيها استهلاك
الزخائد انا اعتقد انه يعني
حتى جسمانيا انا اعتقد انهم استهلكم هؤلاء
الافراد لانه لا يوجد لديهم الان معسكر
يمكن ان ينالوا فيه غصبا من الراحه
مثل ولكن يعني حضره الفريق اذا نستمع الى
تصريحات قوات الدعم السريع دائما يصرون
ويقولون بانهم ما زالوا في قلب المعركه
وبانهم لن يتراجعوا
لن يتراجعوا قبل تحقيق الديمقراطيه للشعب
السوداني يعني هذه التصريحات التي نسمعها
من الدعم السريع باي اطار يمكن ان نضعها
في اطار واحد فقط الفار الذي وضعنا فيه
تصريحات وزير الثقافه العراقي عند غزو
الامريكان الى بغداد والوزير الثقافه
الصحافه يغلف على الجسر ويقول سندمر هؤلاء
العلوي يعني في في هذا هو الرباط ليس ليس
اطارها
يقولون
على معظم المناطق بعدين يجب ان نفهم انه
السودان ده ليست هو الخرطوم ليست هو
المنتج المركزيه التي يدور فيها الاشتباك
في كل يوم سودان 18 ولايه الان 17 ولايه
امنه ان لم نقول
بنسبه اكثر من 98% الخرطوم نفسها
ام المناطق في اطراف العاصمه امنه
الاشتباكات فيها تكاد تكون معدومه
معركه
حضرتك بانه يعني هذه المعركه وهذا النزاع
سينتهي بايام ولن يطول اكثر من ذلك
بالتاكيد لن يكون بالعشر يعني نحن حسب
قراءتنا نعتقد الان هذا النزاع
تجاوز بكثير الزمن الذي كنا نعتقد انه
سيحسن فيه ويمكن ذلك لسببين السبب الاول
انه المجموعات الان معظم المجموعات الان
المتمركزه في الخرطوم تتخذ دروعا بشريه
لتحمي بها نفسها من هجمات الجيش السبب
الاخر انا اعتقد انه الدعم السريع كل
عناصر من كل الولايات داخل الخرطوم واصبح
اصبحت الاعداد كعدداد بشري يعني ضخمه جدا
وهذا ايضا يزيد من امثله يعني
في خلال سته ايام الماضيه تكبت خسائر
مهوله في المعدات في الافراد في يعني هذا
يجعل منهم ان كانوا يحسبون حسابات المعارك
يجب ان يستسلموا يجب ان يوقفوا هذا التمرد
لانه بذلك يبنوا يبنوا شبابهم يعني شكرا
لك المحل العسكرية الفريق فتح الرحمن محي
الدين على المشاركه معنا
[موسيقى]
حضر قيادي النا في قوى الحريه وتغيير
السودانيه في تصريحات لصحيفه السودان
تريبيون من ان استمرار الحربي سيؤدي الى
ما وصفه بتدخل اقليمي واسع يحول السودان
الى دويلات متنازعه ونقلت الصحيفه عن
القيادي في الحريه وتغيير ياسر عرمان قوله
وان الحل الوحيد في السودان هو تشكيل كتله
مدنيه صلبه ومتحده ضد الحرب مشددا على انه
من دون ذلك ستتمزق البلاد دون رحمه
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الامريكيه انها تراقب
الوضع في السودان مع استمرار المعارك هناك
وتجري تقييما لحالات اجلاء طارئه
البانتاجون يستعد لارسال عددا اضافي من
الجنود الى معسكر لموني التابعه للبحريه
الامريكيه في جيبوتي ومن المتوقع ان تعمل
القوات على تامين وتسهيل مغادره موظفي
السفاره الامريكيه من الخرطوم اذا اقتضت
الظروف واشارت مصادر الى وجود اتصالات بين
وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه وطرفين نزاع في
السودان لضمان عمليه الاجلاء
اصبحت اصبحت مشاهد الاشتباكات واطلاق
النار في السودان مالوفه مقاطع فيديو
انتشرت تظهر مواطنين يفطرون على اصوات
اطلاق النار الكثيف فيما جلس اخرون
يتابعون المواجهات بين الجيش السوداني
والدعم السريع
ليست مشاهد من فيلم سينمائي ولا مقاطع
مركبه في السودان اضحت اصوات اطلاق النار
مالوفه الى درجه التطبيع معها بعد يوم
طويل من الصيام مواطنون سودانيون يفطرون
على اصوات اطلاق النار الكثيف والقتال
المستعر بين الجيش والدعم السريع
قبل ذلك جلس اخرون متابعين للاشتباكات
وكان الامر يتعلق بمسرح في الهواء الطلق
غير ان الكلفه البشريه للوضع ترتفع يوما
بعد يوم
[موسيقى]
وضعوا الى كويس
قالت الامم المتحده انما بين 10 الى 20
الف شخصا فروا من السودان الى تشاد بسبب
تدهور الوضع الامني الناتج عن الصراع بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع وعبرت
الامم المتحده عن قلقها الشديد من تصاعد
العنف وتطورات الوضع في السودان والذي
سيكون له تاثير سلبي على حياه المواطنين
وعلى طرق تقديم المساعدات الانسانيه التي
اصبحت صعبه في الفتره الاخيره
للامم المتحده
في السودان بوقف اطلاق النار داعيا لهدنه
تمتد لثلاثه ايام طوال فتره عيد الفطر
كاولويه فوريه اناشد اطراف النزاع وقف
اطلاق النار لمده ثلاثه ايام على الاقل
احتفالا بعيد الفطر للسماح للمدنيين
بالفرار من مناطق النزاع والبحث عن العلاج
الطبي والامدادات الضروريه الاخرى يجب ان
يتبع ذلك حوار يسمح بالانتقال الناجح
للبدء بتعيين حكومه مدنيه يجب ان يتوقف
القتال فورا انا ايضا قلق للغايه بشان
حاله العديد من الاشخاص العاملين في الامم
المتحده داخل منطقه النزاع
اك
دت اطفال واصابه اكثر من 50 اخرين في
الاشتباكات الدائره في السودان واوضح بيان
اليونيسيف ان العديد من العائلات في
السودان محاصره بسبب التبادل اطلاق النار
كما اجبر الالاف على مغادره المنازل بحثا
عن مكان امن كما اكدت انها لا يمكنها
تقديم المساعده الانسانيه دون ضمانات
لسلامه موظفيها
في تصريحات للعربيه اوضح المتحدث باسم
وزاره الصحه السودانيه محمد ابراهيم ان 30
مستشفى خرجت عن الخدمه في العاصمه الخرطوم
وحدها مشيرا الى ان مخزون الادويه والدم
لا يزال جيدا في مستشفيات الخرطوم
عدد المصابين في الخمسه ايام السابقه اللي
هو منذ يوم 15 وحتى فجر اليوم
1722 مصاب واتوا الى الاستشفاء في
مستشفيات الولايه البالغ عددها 133 مستشفى
45 مستشفى
القطاع الخاص مجمل الوفيات
سجلت في المستشفيات
145 في الغطاء العام
59 في القطعه الخاص
[موسيقى]
في تصريحاتنا العربيه اوضح وزير الصحه
السودانيه هيثم ابراهيم ان هناك حاجه
لتامين مسارات انسانيه لايصال المساعدات
للمحتاجين مؤكدا ان مراكز طبيه تعرضت
للحرق الكامل في السودان
الموجود في الامدادات
محتاجين انه يصل لمواقع المستشفيات كذلك
محتاجين لمساله تامين وصول الكوادر الطبيه
وايجاد مسارات لانه برضه هناك عدد من
الكوادر الطبيه تعمل في هذه المستشفيات
خمسه او سته ايام متصله بالليل والنهار
مقدمين العمل الانساني الكبير والجليل
فبالتالي احنا محتاجين لتامين مسارات
لاعطاء ومسارات الامداد وايصال الوقود
للمستشفيات التامه تحديدا بصوره اساسيه
كما نحتاج كذلك لمساله ضروره التامين
المستشفيات الصحيه والامدادات الطبيه
كما افاد وزير الصحه السودانيه هيثم
ابراهيم بان مستشفيات العاصمه الخرطوم
الاكثر تاثرا جراء الاشتباكات مشيرا الى
ان انظمه الكهرباء والمياه لحقتها اضرار
كبير في ولايه الخرطوم تاشرت المستشفيات
واولاد الخرطوم فيها حوالي
125 مستشفى ما بين القطاعين العام والخاص
المستشفيات المركزيه بصوره اساسيه اللي هي
فيها النقاط الاشتباك ابي صوره كبيره في
مركز الخرطوم
التي
وصارت فيها صعوبه في التشغيل
بصوره نسبيه عاد الهدوء الى مدينه مروي في
الولايه الشماليه بعد اعلان الجيش سيطرته
على المطار والقاعده الجويه الكاميرا
العربيه تناقلت في عدد من شوارع واحياء
المدينه ورصدت حاله الاستقرار
بعد سته ايام من الاشتباكات المسلحه
والعمليات العسكريه بين الجيش وقوات الدعم
السريع كيف تبدو الاوضاع الرهينه داخل
مدينه مروي نحن هنا لنجيب على هذا التساؤل
كان في اغلب الناس رحلوا من المنطقه مشوش
شريكوا كريمه الحمد لله الليله من الصباح
النصر رجعوا البيوت ورجعوا للترتيبات
والحاجاتهم للعيد وربنا يطمن الناس اكثر
واكثر ان شاء الله يا رب الحمد لله وسع
الحيوان يستقر الحمد لله احنا ناشد عن
القوات المسلحه
والدعم السريع
يرجع لصوت العقل ويحفظ دماء الشعب
السوداني قال الحمد لله عمنا البلد امنه
والناس كلهم يعني في شغل معادل هنا يومين
ثلاثه الحمد لله رب العالمين نحن رسالتنا
ربنا يصلح ذات البين اي ناس مختلفين مع
بعض يسووا امور يسووا مع بعض يتفقوا عشان
ما يضرروا المواطن المواطنين دول ناس
تعبانين الناس عايشين عي شه صعبه جدا جدا
يقول الحمد لله على السلامه
وربنا يقوي جيشنا ويدينا الصحه والعافيه
وكل سنه وانتم طيبين
عناصر من الجيش السوداني
بعد اشتباك مع قوات الدعم السريع ووجدوا
في مركبات عسكريه جثثا لجنود بالاضافه
لسياره مواطن تظهر فيها دماء
اكثر من 16
جيناك تحت مقلوب
تمام
[موسيقى]
مواطن والجثه بتاعته وشالوها شكله
شايفين الرصاص
والنباتات قليلا عن الاشتباكات في السودان
لدقائق لنتابع معكم موجز لاهم الاخبار
[موسيقى]
اكد الامين العام لحلفي شمال الاطلس اثناء
زياره الى كيف ان اولويات الحلف تتمثل
بضمان تغلب اوكرانيا في الحرب على روسيا
مضيفا ان مستقبل اوكرانيا هو داخل العائله
الاوروبيه الاطلسيه وسيتم بحث خطط
انضمامها للحلف خلال القمه التي ستعقد في
شهر يوليو
الرئيس في مبادره دعم متعدده سيساعد هذا
على الانتقال من معدات ومبادئ الحقبه
السوفياتيه الى معايير حلف شمال الاطلسي
وضمان العمل المشترك مع الحلف انها شهاده
على الالتزام النيتو طويل الاجل تجاه
اوكرانيا حلف شمال الاطلسيه يقف معكم
اليوم وغدا وكلما استدعى الامر ذلك
من جهته قال الرئيس الاوكراني الوقت حان
لدعوه كياف للانضمام الى حلف شمال الاطلسي
واتخاذ القرار المناسب واشدد ايلينسكي لدى
لقائه ستنبرغ في على ضروره ان تدعم كل
الدول في الناتو انضمام اوكرانيا الى
صفوفه
نحن لا نعد بديلا لعضويه النيتو ونفكر في
حل وسط انا لا اقول هذا لمجتمعنا الان
لانه على ما اعتقد يدرك ذلك بوضوح انا
الان اقول هذا لقاده هؤلاء البلدان التي
تبحث باستمرار عن حل الوسط لعضويه
اوكرانيا المستقبليه في النيتو سنكون في
الحلف نعتقد ان هذا ضمان لامن اوكرانيا
بتنفيذ عشر طلعات جويه لدعم وحدات الهجوم
فيسكا وتدمير مقر قياديه اوكرانيه على
الجبهه واشارت موسكو الى ان مدفعيه مجموعه
القوات الجنوبيه نفذت 64 مهمه قصف ومنعت
القوات الاوكرانيه من القيام بهجوم مضاد
ابدت الاداره الذاتيه الكرديه التي تسيطر
على مناطق واسعه شمال وشمال شرق سوريا
ابدت موافقه مشروطه على لقاء الحكومه
السوريه للتواصل الى حل للازمه بينهما
الاداره الذاتيه اكدت في بيانها ضروره
تمسك بوحده الاراضي السوريه وتاسيس نظام
اداري سياسي ديمقراطي تعددي وتوزيع
الثروات والموارد الاقتصاديه بشكل عادل
بين المناطق السوريه حسب قولها
مع اولى جولات الرئيس الفرنسي امانويل
ماكرون بعد قانون رفع سن التقاعد تجمع
حوالي 250 شخصا في الجان جنوب غرب فرنسا
للاحتجاج على سياسه ماكرون
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
من جهته قال ماكرون انه مستعد للحديث مع
معارضي قانون رفع السن التقاعدي الذي تم
تمريره الشهر الماضي
اذا كانوا مستعدين للتحدث نحن جاهزون لكن
اذا كان الهدف فقط هو طرح مزيد من المشاكل
واحداث الضوضاء فهذا لا يستحق كل هذا
العناء لذلك سنرى كيف ستسيل الامور اولا
اذا المشاهدينا نتابع هذه الصور الخاصه
للعربيه تكدس المواطنين امام محطات الوقود
اذا هذه الصور الخاصه بالعربيه نتابع فيها
المواطنين
يصطفون طوابير امام محطات الوقود وطبعا
يعني هذا الامر كنا تبعناه منذ اليوم
الاول دائما ضيوفنا وايضا زملائنا في
الخرطوم كانوا يتحدثوا عن هذه الازمه
وبانه هناك اقتضاض للسكان للمواطنين امام
محطات الوقود نظرا لعدم قدره ايصال هذا
الوقود الى المحطات بسبب الاشتباكات
الحاصله في بعض المناطق
اذا مشاهدينا ما زلنا نتابع هذه الصور
الخاصه بالعربيه لتكدس المواطنين امام
محطه وقود في الخرطوم طبعا هناك ايضا حركه
نزوح من المناطق التي تشهد اشتباكات
وبالتالي هذه الازمه ازمه الوقود كانت منذ
اليوم الاول لبدء هذا النزاع المسلح
اذا مشاهدينا هذه التغطيه على العربيه ما
زالت مستمره ولكن الان ننتقل الى الزميله
راويه قاسم لنتابع معها التطورات هناك
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات